this program is brought to you by Emory
University
everybody who had antibiotic to the
virus was still infected with the virus
so unfortunately unlike most viruses
exposure and infection meant lifelong
infection and then even more
unfortunately it was progressive so it
looked like everybody infected with the
virus would ultimately died from the
virus so when you did a survey of a
hundred people and twenty people had it
for most of us that meant that twenty
people would die unless treatments and
better care could be made available
prevention recommendations came out
before the virus was discovered and they
were pretty cogent they helped us avoid
transmission to healthcare and
laboratory workers by following
hepatitis B precautions avoid sexual
contact with people who might be
affected or at high risk and avoid
donating blood if we're in a group that
was at high risk for AIDS these
recommendations still make a lot of
sense after the virus was discovered in
a 1987 AZT was discovered it's a drug
that was too toxic for cancer discovered
by a man named Jerome Horowitz in
Michigan Michigan Cancer Foundation in
1970 and it was to can't too toxic for
cancer patients that they tried on
parent must not work very well either
and so they put it on the shelf and
Burroughs Wellcome bought it and was
sitting on the shelf until Bobby our
Chauhan and Sam Broder at the National
Cancer Institute found that it was
effective in vitro against HIV and then
was soon tried in trial and it was a
proof-of-concept at an antiretroviral
drug would work at that time doctors and
infectious disease doctors were very
skeptical of antivirals in general there
were only a couple that had marginal
efficacy and people thought there's
never going to be anything it's going to
work against something that's
complicated as aids and AZT didn't work
very well however there were courageous
trial that ended in 1993 called the 076
trial which was a trial that
demonstrated giving AZT to pregnant
women before delivery during delivery
into the baby afterwards greatly reduced
the transmission to babies again many
skeptics including some here in Atlanta
about that trial
but it really worked and was an
important proof of concept that really
revolutionized their ability to prevent
transmission to newborns and finally in
1995 highly active antiretroviral
therapy or heart became demonstrated to
really alter the course of the epidemic
for millions of people throughout the
world at first really just a developed
world it was never going to be available
to people in developing countries
because it would be too expensive but
due to a lot of forces including the
lobbying of many many doctors in the
developed world and activists the prices
went down and now there are five million
people perhaps on antiretrovirals
throughout the world still far too few
but far more than anybody could have
predicted now there's going to be many
continuing breakthroughs we don't know
of any magical breakthroughs coming
through in the next week or year or two
years but there'll be many continuing
biologic breakthroughs and behavioural
breakthroughs they include post-exposure
prophylaxis prep the 05 to trial you
heard about today even tightly more
tightly linking therapy with HIV to
prevention or transmission with HIV none
of these things taken individually are
going to change the course of the
epidemic but combined they tell us that
there's going to be a need for continued
good care linking prevention and care
and continuing commitment on many of us
and that scientific breakthroughs will
continue that they're not stalled the
preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University